all right good afternoon i'm lieutenant
ray spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department
i'm out here this afternoon a briefing
on a homicide investigation that we are
conducting in the 2600 block
of south pavilion center drive which is
a residential area
near the intersections of sahara and the
215
west bound the details that i have right
now i'm sharing are very preliminary but
at around 9
49 this morning officers received a 911
call
from a male stating that he had been
involved in a shooting and had
shot his daughter medical personnel and
police arrived
and located a white female in her late
20's suffering from multiple gunshot
wounds
that female was transported to umc
trauma where she was
later pronounced deceased we have a
white male who is in his early 60s who's
the father of the deceased
currently detained he is being
interviewed by detectives
as i'm speaking with you it's still very
early on in the investigation we do not
know exactly what led up to the shooting
but i urge anybody who has any
information to reach out to crime
stoppers and that information can be
completely anonymous so again i'll
answer a couple questions but it's very
early on in this investigation
um i'm assuming this was it was light
enough outside to see that this was his
daughter that he was shooting at or was
this some sort of mistake
no he uh from the details that we're
getting preliminarily
he knew that it was his daughter uh when
the shooting occurred there has been
some initial claims of self-defense that
we are still trying to corroborate
and that's where we're at in the
investigation trying to figure out what
exactly
led up to him shooting his daughter
again i don't have that detail as far as
the uh prior calls to the address we're
still working on that
as i'm talking with you it happened
inside any department yes it happened
inside the apartment the two lived
together in an apartment directly behind
us
and they've lived at the apartments
together for a couple years and the 911
no the shooter who's the father he's the
person who actually called
to report the incident and have you
talked to any neighbors
so right now we are in the process of
speaking with a couple neighbors
is trying to locate anyone who may have
heard anything and that's why i urge
anybody who has any of those details to
call
at this point we have not located anyone
yet who heard the gunfire
uh you gave us the age of the shooter
you did not give us the age of the
daughter
i did she's a white female in her late
20s yes
all right do you know how long they've
lived here how long they've been living
in the same apartment
i believe they've lived here for a
couple years together all right
thank you guys appreciate it